at the World Economic Forum on East Asia
in Vietnam we're setting up a Davos
debates video corner here participants
including presidents and business
leaders will respond via video to your
questions and ideas on the region's
future the meeting is under the theme
rethinking Asia's leadership agenda the
key question we want to discuss with you
is how can a sure lead the world the
19th World Economic Forum on East Asia
would explore the many facets of the
region's rising influence what questions
do you have for the leaders who will
gather in ho chi minh city from the
sixth to the seventh of jun 2010 send
your ideas and questions via video or
text to youtube.com slash Davos you can
also vote on your favorite contributions
from others the contributions with the
highest number of votes will be put to
the leaders at the Davos debates corner
giving direct access to some of the most
powerful and influential people in the
world the best entries may also be shown
at the meeting tell us what you think go
to youtube.com slash Davos to join the
conversation